>>> WE BEGIN WITH THE STAGGERING
COVID NUMBERS.
THE U.S. IS NOW AVERAGING MORE
THAN 237,000 NEW DAILY CASES,
AND SEVERAL STATES ARE NEAR
ALL-TIME PEAK COVID
HOSPITALIZATION LEVELS.
NOW THE STARK RISE COMES AS THE
CDC ANNOUNCED IT'S CUTTING THE
RECOMMENDED ISOLATION PERIOD FOR
ASYMPTOMATIC INFECTED AMERICANS
IN HALF.
INSTEAD OF STAYING AWAY FROM
OTHER PEOPLE FOR TEN DAYS THE
CDC SAYS STAY HOME FOR JUST
FIVE, THAT'S IF YOU'RE
ASYMPTOMATIC BY DAY FIVE.
NOW THE AGENCY SAYS THE CHANGE
IS DRIVEN BY DATA SHOWING MOST
COVID TRANSMISSION HAPPENS ONE
TO TWO DAYS BEFORE SOMEONE HAS
SYMPTOMS, AND IN A TWO TO THREE
DAYS AFTER.
WANT TO GET STRAIGHT TO CNN
MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT ELIZABETH
COHEN.
THIS IS A MAJOR CHANGE.
WHAT KIND OF PRECIPITATED THIS?
>> WHAT PRECIPITATED IS, PHIL,
WAS THE STATISTIC YOU JUST GAVE
WHERE THEY SAID, LOOK, IF YOU'RE
MOST SYMPTOMATIC RIGHT BEFORE
AND TWO OR THREE DAYS AFTER
EXPOSURE, WHY ARE WE KEEPING
PEOPLE OUT FOR TEN DAYS?
THEY STARTED TO SEE WE'RE LOSING
DOCTORS.
WE'RE LOSING NURSES AND PEOPLE,
FOR EXAMPLE WORKS WORK FOR
AIRLINES WHICH IS WHY YOU'RE
SEEING SO MANY CANCELLED FLIGHTS
SO THEY SAID LET'S TAKE THESE
STEPS.
I MUST SAY WHEN I TALK TO
INFECTIOUS DISEASE EXPERTS WHO
HAVE ALWAYS FELT VERY FREE TO
CRITICIZE THE CDC AND DO SO
OFTEN THEY WERE REALLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS, SO LET'S TAKE A
LOOK AGAIN AT WHAT YOU WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT.
SO THE CDC USED TO SAY ISOLATE
FOR TEN DAYS IF YOU HAVE COVID.
NOW THEY SAY IF YOU'RE
ASYMPTOMATIC, YOU HAVE COVID BUT
YOU'RE ASYMPTOMATIC OR YOU HAVE
SYMPTOMS AND THEY ARE GETTING
BETTER, ISOLATE FOR FIVE DAYS
AND THEN WEAR A MASK AROUND
OTHERS FOR FIVE DAYS.
NOW, LET'S SAY YOU'RE EXPOSED,
SOMEONE IN YOUR FAMILY, FOR
EXAMPLE, HAS COVID.
YOU DON'T HAVE COVID BUT YOU
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED.
THEY USED TO SAY TO QUARANTINE.
NOW THEY ARE SAYING IF YOU'VE
BEEN VACCINATED AND HAVE
RECEIVED A BOOSTER OR IF YOUR
SECOND SHOT WAS WITHIN THE PAST
SIX MONTHS, NO QUARANTINE IS
NECESSARY BUT DO WEAR A MASK FOR
TEN DAYS.
THE REASON FOR THAT, THE CDC
SAYS THAT AS LONG AS YOU'VE HAD
A BOOSTER SHOT, THAT YOU ARE 75%
PROTECTED AGAINST OMICRON
INFECTION.
SO THEY ARE SAYING IF YOU'RE 75%
PROTECTED AGAINST OMICRON,
YOU'RE NOT SICK, YOU DON'T HAVE
IT, YOU'RE NOT SHOWING SIGNS,
WHY SHOULD YOU BE QUARANTINED?
SO, YOU KNOW, THIS WILL REALLY
COME INTO PLAY AS OMICRON STARTS
SPREADING IN BIGGER NUMBERS
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
WE'LL SEE HOW THIS NEW POLICY
WORKS OUT.
PHIL?
>> YEAH.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
I DO WANT A QUICK FOLLOW-UP.
THE CDC JUST ANNOUNCED THE
NUMBER OF NEW CASES CAUSED BY
OMICRON WAS LESS THAN 60% LAST
WEEK.
I WAS A LITTLE CONFUSED WHEN I
SAW THAT NUMBER COMPARED TO WHAT
WE'VE SEEN THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THESE NEW
NUMBERS?
>> YEAH, IT'S REALLY CONFUSING
WHAT'S HAPPENED HERE, AND I'M
GOING TO SPELL THIS ALL OUT AND
TRY TO SORT OF GO SLOWLY.
SO THE CDC EVERY WEEK PUTS OUT
REPORTS.
ALL THE NEW CASES OUT THERE, "X"
PERCENT ARE DELTA AND "Y"% ARE
ONLY CRONE AND THEY HAVE BEEN
DOING THIS THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC.
THE CDC SAID THE WEEK OF
DECEMBER 18th, THEY PREVIOUSLY
SAID NEW CASES WERE 73% OMICRON
AND EVERYONE WAS LIKE, WOW, THAT
GOT VERY BIG VERY QUICKLY.
NOW THEY ARE SAYING, WE'RE
REVISING THAT ESTIMATE.
WE THINK IT'S ACTUALLY 23%.
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY A GIGANTIC
DIFFERENCE, AND THEY SAY THE
WEEK OF DECEMBER 19th THROUGH
25th WAS 59%, SO OMICRON DOES
NOT SEEM TO BE SPREADING QUITE
AS QUICKLY.
DELTA IS STILL HOLDING ITS OWN.
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
IT IS UNCLEAR.
ONE THING THAT WE KNOW, YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE THINK, PHIL, THAT
EVERY -- THAT WE DO GENETIC
SEQUENCING FOR EVERY CASE, WE
DON'T.
WE HAVE TO DO ESTIMATES.
WE DO A FEW AND THEN WE
ESTIMATE, BUT IT'S A BIT OF A
PROBLEM THAT THIS HAPPENED
BECAUSE YOU START MAKING
TREATMENT DECISIONS BASED ON
THESE NUMBERS, AND THAT NUMBER
AUSTIN POWERS TO HAVE BEEN
WILDLY OFF.
PHIL?
>> YEAH.
THAT MIGHT EVEN BE AN
UNDERSTATEMENT STILL.
EVOLUTION AND REALTIME.
ELIZABETH COHEN, THANKS FOR
EXPLAINING IT TO US, SLOWLY.
APPRECIATE IT AS ALWAYS.
>>> WANT TO BRING IN FORMER
BALTIMORE HEALTH COMMISSIONER
DR. LEANA WEN.
DOCTOR BEFORE WE KIND OF GO
THROUGH THINGS HERE, I WANT YOU
TO TAKE A LISTEN TO HOW
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI KIND OF WALKED
THROUGH THE NEW GUIDELINES FROM
THE CDC ON CNN LAST NIGHT.
>> SO IT JUST MAKES SENSE IF YOU
KEEP THEM OUT FOR FIVE DAYS,
KEEP THEM ISOLATED FOR FIVE
DAYS, THEN GET THEM BACK DOING
THEIR JOB, DOING THEIR WORK,
KEEPING A MASK ON TO PROTECTING
THEMSELVES FROM INFECTING OTHER
INDIVIDUALS, SO I DON'T THINK
IT'S CONFUSING.
I THINK THAT'S A RATHER CRISP
RECOMMENDATION.
>> DR. WEN, I THINK ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THE CDC WAS CITING
RESEARCH AND SCIENCE AND DATA
BEHIND THE DECISION HERE, BUT I
THINK THERE'S BEEN SOME QUESTION
IS THIS BECAUSE OF THE SCALE OF
THE SPREAD, A DECISION ABOUT
KEEPING BUSINESSES OPEN?
IS IT A MEDICAL DECISION?
IS IT A POLITICAL DECISION?
IS IT ALL OF THEM COMBINED?
WHERE ARE WE ON THIS?
>> WELL, PHIL, I'M RELIEVED THAT
THE CDC CAME OUT WITH THIS
GUIDANCE BECAUSE WE ARE FACING
THE IMMINENT COLLAPSE OF SO MANY
FUNCTIONS IN OUR SOCIETY.
WE ALREADY ARE ABOUT TO SURPASS
THE PEAK OF COVID CASES LAST
WINTER, AND BY THE WAY, WE'RE
VASTLY UNDERCOUNTING RATHER
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE UNABLE TO GET
TESTS AND ALSO RAPID TESTS ARE
NOT BEING REPORTED TO PUBLIC
HEALTH AUTHORITIES.
WE COULD VERY WE'LL GET TO THE
POINT OF HAVING A MILLION NEW
COVID INFECTIONS EVERY DAY.
WHEN WE'RE AT THAT KIND OF LEVEL
YOU CAN'T KEEP PEOPLE OUT FOR
TEN DAYS IN ISOLATION BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT GOING HAVE POLICE
OFFICERS.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
FIREFIGHTERS.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS.
WE'RE JUST NOT GOING TO HAVE A
FUNCTIONING SOCIETY SO I'M
RELIEVED THAT THE CDC CAME TO
THIS DECISION.
IT IS BASED ON THE SCIENCE AS
WELL.
ALTHOUGH I WILL SAY IDEALLY WHAT
WE REALLY WANT IS TO HAVE A TEST
IN ORDER NO EXIT ISOLATION, TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE NO LONGER
INFECTIOUS.
AS WE KNOW THERE AREN'T ENOUGH
TESTS SO I THINK THIS IS THE
BEST OF BOTH WORLDS, IF YOU
WILL, THAT IT'S REALLY A
PRACTICAL DECISION BASED ON
SCIENCE BUT ULTIMATELY DRIVEN BY
PRACTICALITIES, BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT PUBLIC HEALTH IS ABOUT.
IT'S ABOUT MEETING THE REALITIES
ON THE GROUND.
IT'S NOT ABOUT AIMING FOR
PERFECT.
IT'S RECOGNIZING THAT WE'RE IN
AN IMPERFECT AND PRETTY DIRE
SITUATION, AND THIS IS THE
REASON WHY WE HAVE TO SHORTEN
THAT ISOLATION PERIOD.
>> BUT YOU HIT ON A REALLY GOOD
POINT WHEN I WAS READING THROUGH
THE KNEW GUIDANCE YESTERDAY.
I KEPT WAITING ONCE YOU TEST
TWICE WITH AN ANTIGEN PLACE, THE
NBA SAYS PLAYERS CAN RETURN SIX
DAYS AFTER TESTING POSITIVE IF
THE TESTS SHOW THEY ARE NO
LONGER INFECTIOUS.
IS A DEARTH OF TESTS WHY THE CDC
DIDN'T ISSUE A SIMILAR
PRE-REQUISITE HERE?
>> I BELIEVE SO, AND I WISH THEY
JUST CAME OUT AND SAID IT IN THE
SAME WAY THAT BACK LAST MARCH
WHEN THE CDC WAS NOT
RECOMMENDING MASKS AND WAS
GIVING ALL KINDS OF OTHER
REASONS FOR WHY MASKS WERE NOT
RERNLGSD I WISH THAT THEY HAD
COME OUT THEN AND SAID THE REAL
REASON IS THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MASKS FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS, AND, THEREFORE, WE
SHOULD BE SAVING THESE
HIGH-QUALITY MASKS FOR HEALTH
CARE WORKERS, NOT THAT MASKS
AREN'T NEEDED BUT THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH MASKS.
I THINK THIS IS THE SAME THING
HERE, TOO.
TESTS ARE ACTUALLY NEEDED IN
ORDER TO EXIT ISOLATION, BUT IF
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE ENOUGH TESTS
RIGHT NOW TO TEST SYMPTOMATIC
PEOPLE, THEN WE CANNOT POSSIBLY
ISSUE A GUIDANCE FOR ALL OF
AMERICA TO EXIT ISOLATION THAT
WAY SO PRACTICAL REASONS, AND I
WISH THEY WERE FORTHCOMING ABOUT
THE PRACTICAL ASPECTS OF WHY
THEY ARE MAKING THIS DECISION,
WHICH I STILL BELIEVE IS THE
RIGHT ONE.
>> YEAH.
IT'S -- IT'S A BIG QUESTION MARK
FOR ME THOUGH.
I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY THE
LIKELY ANSWER, AS YOU SAID.
LAST ONE BEFORE I LET YOU GO.
WE'VE BEEN WATCHING CASES,
PEDIATRIC CASES OF COVID I THINK
SKYROCKET TO SOME DEGREE, AT
LEAST IN PLACES LIKE NEW YORK
CITY.
THEY ARE ANECDOTAL.
WE'VE SEEN THEM JUMP NO,
QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
PEDIATRIC HOSPITALIZATIONS IN
NEW YORK CITY INCREASED FIVEFOLD
AND CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN
CHICAGO QUADRUPLED IN A WEEK.
CLOSE TO HALF ALL OF THE TESTS
AT CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN D.C.
ARE COMING BACK POSITIVE.
YOU'RE A MOM AND TWO
UNVACCINATED KIDS OUT OF THREE.
WHAT ARE YOU SAYING TO PARENTS
IN TERMS OF ADVICE AS WE ALL
LOOK TO SCHOOL RESTARTING HERE
IN ABOUT A WEEK IN TERMS OF HOW
TO MANAGE THIS MOMENT IN TIME?
>> YEAH.
IT'S A DANGEROUS TIME FOR OUR
CHILDREN.
THE SPIKE IN INFECTIONS THAT
WE'RE SEEING IN CHILDREN IS NOT
UNEXPECTED BECAUSE WE'RE SEEING
THE SPIKE IN ADULTS, AND WE KNOW
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE VACCINATED
AND BOOSTED ARE VERY WELL
PROTECTED AGAINST SEVERE
ILLNESS, BUT OUR CHILDREN, MANY
OF WHOM ARE STILL UNVACCINATED,
ARE NOT PROTECTED BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT VACCINATED, AND SO I
WOULD SAY FOR CHILDREN AGES 5
AND ABOVE, GET YOUR VACCINE OR
TO THE PARENTS OF THESE KIDS TO
GET THESE CHILDREN THE VACCINES.
THAT WILL PROTECT THEM.
FOR CHILDREN YOUNGER THAN FIVE
THE BEST WE CAN DO IS SURROUND
THEM BY PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED AND BOOSTED.
I WOULD STILL SAY SEND YOUR
CHILDREN TO SCHOOL, BUT IDEALLY,
AGAIN, THE SCHOOLS SHOULD BE
IMPLEMENTING THESE -- THESE
PROTECTIVE MEASURES THAT WE KNOW
ARE EFFECTIVE.
WE KNOW THAT MASKING IN SCHOOLS,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE HIGH QUALITY
MASKS, ARE VERY PROTECTIVE.
WE KNOW THAT TESTING CAN HELP TO
KEEP KIDS IN SCHOOL SAFELY, SO
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF MEASURES
THAT WE SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTING.
KEEP YOUR KIDS IN SCHOOL.
SURROUND THEM WITH PEOPLE WHO
ARE VACCINATED AND REDUCE RISK
IN OTHER WAYS.
DON'T ALSO HAVE INDOOR PLAY
DATES.
FOCUS ON KEEPING OUR KIDS IN
SCHOOL LEARNING.
>> YEAH.
THERE ARE ROAD MAPS